So, do is it and I'm asking you
genuinely. It's it's up to you, brother.
It's it's in your heart. Do you today
want to turn to God and trust in him for
your salvation? Is that what you want to
do today?
>> Of course.
>> Of course. He said of God, man. Praise
God, man.
>> It's
[Music]
not
yet.
>> Not yet.
>> Not yet. Okay, no worries. Uh wife, can
you go in my backpack, please? on the
side. And can you get the Quran?
>> Thank you, sweetheart. It's on the side.
Right there. Right there. The side
pocket. There it is.
>> Oh, which Quran? The the the wars.
>> Thank you, sweetheart. I can you help
me? Can you stand on his side here?
>> Oh, yeah. You Yeah. You hold the mic for
him. You get you get the verse. It goes
right to left.
>> Goes right to left. Yeah, it goes right
to left.
>> Where you want to go? Um, so I want you
to show him. So, so what we're going to
do is I'm going to show you a couple
verses in the Quran, right? Okay. No,
hold the mic to him. We're going to show
you.
>> Huh? I got to hold the mic.
>> No, no, he's he's going to hold it. No,
you're good. You're good. So, I'm going
to show you a huge problem to me. Okay.
As a Christian, as a Christian reading
this, this is the issue that I have.
Okay. So, I want you to go to 7 157.
Somebody out in the crowd shouted it
out, too. So, this is in the Quran
chapter 7 vers1 157. How long you been a
Muslim?
like I'd say maybe
2016 probably.
>> Since 2016. So you converted?
>> Um yeah, probably.
>> Yeah. Okay. Around around that around
that range.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. What were you before you uh
converted to Islam?
>> [__]
>> Say she
What were you before? Were you atheist?
Uh just didn't really have a belief.
>> I didn't have
>> Didn't really have a belief. Okay. So
look, so this is is this the issue here
right here?
>> 157.
>> Yeah. 157. So it says those who follow
the unlettered prophet um who can
neither read nor write whom they find
written with them in the Torah and the
gospel. Right? I'm going to stop there.
So this verse says in the Quran that we
can find the unlettered prophet talking
about Muhammad that we can find Muhammad
mentioned in the Torah and the Gospel.
Right now for me as a Christian this is
interesting obviously because I read the
Bible. I read the Torah. I read the
gospel you know but unfortunately I do
not find Muhammad mentioned in the
scripture. You get what I'm saying? So
if I'm reading this verse here I have to
judge and and say wow the Quran is
making a mistake because Muhammad's not
mentioned anywhere in the Torah or the
Gospel. So, is it fair for me to say
that because the Quran's making a false
claim that therefore it's not really
from God? It's Muhammad's not really a
prophet if it's making this false claim.
You understand what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> So, so what are your thoughts on that if
you had to if you're thinking about
this? Like the the claim is that the
Quran is from God.
>> God can't make mistakes. Do you agree?
>> I agree.
>> Yeah. So, he agrees that God can't make
mistakes.
>> And so, and we all agree with this. Mhm.
>> So if God can't make mistakes, there's
no way that this can be from God if it's
making a mistake like this,
>> right?
>> So my question to you would be if you're
looking at this and thinking about this,
how would you stay a Muslim if it has
false things and false claims? What are
your thoughts?
>> Thoughts? Uh
>> those who follow
>> he's reading the verse.
>> That's right. That's the way we just
read.
>> Read. Yep.
>> So if he's not found in the Torah
gospel, if he's not in there, then this
is false.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> It's cap.
>> It's cap. Exactly. It's cap. It's huge.
But but but and that's the thing for us
for for us, you know, we we like, okay,
making big claims like this, all right,
let's test it. The Quran has given us a
way to verify it or falsify it. Matter
of fact, this is a reason why it's
saying Jews and Christians should
believe. We should believe because that
prophet is found in our scriptures.
>> But he's not.
>> God bless.
>> So therefore,
>> Islam is false. The Quran is false.
>> Mhm.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> Right.
>> So, why would you stay a Muslim if it's
making false claims like this?
>> Why would I stay a Muslim?
>> Yeah. Why? Why would you stay a Muslim?
>> All right. [__] Speak up and hold.
>> Okay. Say something.
>> Why is he not mentioning this?
>> All right. Come on. Come on.
>> Wait wait wait wait.
[Applause]
>> She said that because he was last. He's
not mentioned. The problem is is that
the Bible or the Quran claims the
Bible's predicting Muhammad in the Torah
and the Gospel. We don't find him in
there. Therefore, the Quran is wrong.
Yep. As simple as that. Look, look. I I
hope she's still listening. Is she still
Did she walk away?
>> She she walked away, but maybe
>> maybe she can still hear.
>> The problem with the idea of Muhammad
being the last prophet is that that's
just a claim.
If he's the last prophet, then we should
be able to see him in our scriptures
like he said we would.
>> But if he's not there, then he's not the
last prophet. He's a fraud.
>> It's as simple as that. Now, no
disrespect, but this is just what the
truth is. And if he's not a true
prophet, Islam falls on its face. It's a
false religion. And my brother Farooq
and others like like that sister there
who's very passionate, they've been
duped. They've been lied to. And they've
been living their lives according to a
lie.
>> Do you want to live your life according
to a lie, my brother?
>> Hell no.
>> No. He said he said, "Hell no."
>> That's right, brother. But let me let me
introduce you to something different.
Okay. Um,
>> sweetheart, can you go in my Can you go
in my my book in the second patch? The
second one. Get my Bible out.
>> Oh, yeah. It's good It's good to have
your rib with you, man. Lady Logic. It's
Lady
Logic.
And she cooking too.
>> Get.
>> Yeah. There you go. That That's That Now
that's the reminder. Hold up the
reminder for him, y'all.
>> That's the reminder right there.
>> That's the reminder. Thank you,
sweetheart. Okay. Thank you for giving
me that. Can you go to Isaiah 53 for me?
>> Yes, I can.
>> Thank you, man. So, now I'm about to
show you, bro. Look.
>> So, notice how the Quran said we should
see a prophet in the scriptures. I'm
about to show you what that actually
looks like when we actually read the
scriptures. What happens when we do see
an actual prophet written in there? You
know what I'm saying?
>> You excited to see it?
>> You You ready to see it?
>> Yeah.
>> You ready to see it? So, Isaiah 53. So,
this is in the book of Isaiah.
>> This is written 700 years before Jesus
is born. Okay. Yeah. 700 years. Now, I'm
about to read this. I'm about to read a
few verses, not the whole thing. I'm
going to show you a few things that
you're going to pick up. I want you to
tell me who it sounds like to you, okay?
If you just had to guess, and I
guarantee you, you're going to get it.
All right. So, it says this, uh, we're
going to go with verse number three. It
says, "He was despised and rejected by
men, a man of suffering who knew what
sickness was. He was like one people
turned away from. He was despised and we
didn't uh we didn't value him." Okay?
Yet, he himself bore our sicknesses and
carried our pains. But we But we in turn
regarded him stricken, struck down by
God and afflicted. But he was pierced
because of our transgressions. He was
crushed because of our iniquities.
That's our sins. Uh the punishment for
our peace was on him. So he was punished
for our peace. And it says, "And we are
healed by his wounds." It says, "We all
went astray like sheep. We all have
turned to our own way and the Lord has
punished him for the iniquity of us all.
>> So if you had to guess,
>> if you're thinking about somebody,
you're thinking about somebody who's
despised and rejected by his own people.
People hate him. People despised him.
And he was pierced for our sins. He was
wounded for us. And the punishment that
he took brings us healing. If you had to
guess off the top of your head about a
prophet, who that sounds like, who does
that sound like to you?
>> Should I say anybody?
>> Anybody? Anybody you think?
>> Damn.
Who does it sound like that was punished
for our sins?
>> Mhm.
>> Was bruised for our sins, was pierced
>> for us. Who does that sound like to you
if you just had to think of a popular
story?
his name every day.
>> Every day.
>> No, no. Every day.
>> It's okay. Let Let him Let him guess it.
Let him guess.
>> Do you have any any idea?
>> I'm still thinking, bro.
>> You still thinking?
>> Yeah.
>> Are you Are you familiar with any of the
stories of the prophets?
>> I'm going be honest with you. Not
really.
>> Not really. Oh, no. That's that's okay.
That's okay. So, what this demonstrates,
brother, this is obviously talking about
somebody who suffers for our sins,
>> right? who suffers for our iniquities.
Like he's punished in our place,
>> right? And so, but we turned away from
him. We rejected him. We rebelled
against him. But still, he took our
place and takes our punishment. And that
the Lord puts our sins upon him. Still
not ringing the bell. It's okay. If it's
not ringing the bell, that's all right
cuz you're unfamiliar with this, which
is okay. That's perfectly fine. You're a
fresh mind, which is beautiful, bro.
You're a fresh mind. So, you haven't
been your mind hasn't been poisoned
necessarily. You know, we we can put
that good seed in there, you know.
>> All right. So, go go to uh go for me to
Matthew.
>> Go to Matt. Go to the crucifixion.
Anywhere you anywhere you go.
>> I just go ahead.
>> Uh I say Eric Eric Adams.
>> Who?
>> Eric Adams.
>> Who's that?
>> Who' you say?
>> Eric Adams.
>> Did you say Eric Adams?
>> Who that?
>> The [__] mayor.
>> The mayor.
>> He said the mayor.
>> You think the mayor the mayor died for
our sins? I mean, [__]
>> No, dude.
>> I'm just [__] with Sean. I'm just
>> Yeah, he playing with us.
>> I'm just going to do John 19.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, what we're going to do is we're
going to show you how this was
fulfilled.
>> What this was talking about, remember
>> Isaiah Isaiah is writing 700 years
before Jesus,
>> right? This is uh very long time ago.
Yeah.
>> They're saying they can only hear you on
the live and no one else.
>> They can only hear me on the live.
>> Yeah. Cuz of that. Yeah.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Well, yeah. I don't know what to do. All
right.
>> So, Jesus is on the cross.
>> Yeah. So, Jesus is on the cross here.
>> Pierced.
>> So, it says here,
>> since
it was the preparation day,
uh the Jews did not want the bodies to
remain on the cross on the Sabbath,
right? They requested Pilate have the
men's legs broken
that um that their bodies be taken away.
So the soldiers now this at the
crucifixion. Okay. So the soldiers So
the soldiers came and broke the legs of
the first man and the other one that had
been crucified with him. When they came
to Jesus, they did not break his legs
since they saw that he was already dead.
But one of the soldiers pierced his side
with a spear, and at once blood and
water came out. So remember in Isaiah
53, it talked about how this person was
bruised for us, and how he was pierced
for our transgressions. Right here, what
happens is we have Jesus 700 years
later, he's crucified. His hands and his
feet are pierced on the cross. He's
hanging on the cross. And then the
soldier pierces him in his side with his
spear. So we see that Isaiah 53 is
prophesying, foretelling the crucifixion
and suffering of Jesus Christ. This is
what it looks like when prophecy is
being fulfilled. When we're supposed to
see a prophet in the Old Testament or
the New, if we're supposed to see
somebody uh fulfilling prophecy, this is
what it looks like. We'll see the
prophecy, mention it, and then we'll see
it fulfilled by the person by name.
usually by name, sometimes just by
description. And so here we have the
description of that event. You get what
I'm saying?
>> So we have the event of the prophet
being pierced for our transgressions.
Now, if we go on uh in in John verse
chapter 19, it talks about how they uh
they stole his clothes, right? So watch
this. It says here down here it says uh
for these things happened so that the
scripture would be fulfilled.
Not one of his bones will be broken
also.
Also and another scripture says they
will look at the one they pierced. That
scripture they will look at the one they
pierced. Now let's go to Zechariah real
quick. Zechariah 12. So you see it's
saying this is this scriptur is
fulfilled. This scriptures talked about.
So if we're looking at the scripture and
it's saying this is what the scripture
said, we should find it in the
scripture. Right. Right. Right.
>> So I'm going to show you what it looks
like when a bi when the verse mentions a
passage we should find.
>> Zechariah what?
>> Chapter 12.
>> 12:10.
>> We're going to see what it looks like
when a prophet fulfills prophecy. All
right. So it just said in John 19 that
this was to fulfill when it says and
they will look at him whom they pierced.
Should we find that in the Bible?
>> If we if we just read, we going to find
it.
>> All right. So let's see what happens
when we just read. So it says this God
speaking. Then I will pour out a spirit
of grace and prayer on the house of
David and the residents of Jerusalem,
and they will look at me whom they
pierced. And they will mourn for him as
one mourns for an only child um and weep
bitterly for him as one weeps for a
firstborn. So here in Zechariah, now
Zechariah is around what time? AP do you
do you know Zechariah?
>> Huh? Post exil post exilic. So after
they came back from exile. So they're
back in Jerusalem.
>> Yep. They're back in Jerusalem. After
the exile. So after the exile.
>> Yeah. Stay with him. So after the exile
here they prophesied that God himself
will come in the flesh and be pierced
and they will look at him whom they
pierced. This happened with Jesus Christ
brother. So all these prophecies are
being fulfilled in Jesus. These are
things that we can look at and it
happened in real time in history and
these things really took place.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> So, this shows us that the Bible is
actually true. That the Bible is
actually from God. That he not he didn't
just say, "Hey guys, I'm going to just
create you guys and leave you to
yourselves." But he demonstrated, "Hey
guys, I'm real. This is how you know.
I'm going to say the future and when it
happens, you'll know that I'm the real
God who spoke it from the beginning.
>> This is a way that you know who the true
God is. All right. So, with that being
said, you said that you were Muslim.
>> Do you see the difference between the
Quran saying that we can find a prophecy
and then the Bible actually showing the
prophecy? Do you see the difference?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, like one's a truth,
one's a lie.
>> Exactly. One's the truth and one's a
lie. So, what I'm going to ask you, my
brother, is
>> is you still a Muslim?
>> I mean,
>> you still going to be a Muslim?
>> No.
>> Hey, praise God.
>> Praise God. Praise God. No, no, no.
That's that's huge, brother. It's huge
because a lot of this, it's about truth
and falsehood. We care about your
salvation. You know what I'm saying? We
care about where you go, how you live
here, what you do here, matters where
you go next, right? It's either heaven
or hell. You believe in heaven and hell,
right?
>> All right. So, you believe in heaven and
hell. God has given us a way to know.
You can know right now where you're
going, right? You can know today where
you're going. If you were to die today,
for example, God given, he's given us
laws. He's given us commandments. You
know what I'm saying? And so, based on
these commandments, this is how God
judges our character according to God's
character. For example, God does not
want us to lie. He does not want us to
cheat. He doesn't want us to commit
adultery. He doesn't want us to look at
women with lust or men with lust, right?
He wants us to treat our neighbors as we
love ourselves, right? Love your
neighbor as yourself. These are commands
that God has given. You know what I'm
saying? I would ask you this. Have you
ever lied in your life?
>> I mean,
>> you don't know if you told a lie.
>> I mean, if I did, if I did, it was long
time. It was long time.
>> Long time ago. You probably You just
told a lie just now.
>> No, but but so you've lied before in
your life.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Okay. See, now before God He will
judge you as a liar. Even if it was a
long time ago, you're still stained with
sin.
>> And because with God, he's eternal,
right? He's eternal and he's infinite.
The crimes that you perform against God
remain. They're infinite. They're
eternal,
>> right? Unless unless something is done
where God can erase your sins, erase
your punishment, and wipe you clean of
your of of the judgment that you
deserve. Do you know a way that he did
that?
out.
>> We just read it. Remember Isaiah 53.
He's pierced for our sins, for our
transgressions. The punishment that you
and I deserve was put on Jesus on the
cross.
>> So Jesus on the cross is taking on
everybody's sins in the world, past,
present, and future. So what we what he
does is he dies the death that you and I
deserve. He takes the punishment from
God that you and I deserve. So that now
when you look to the son of God, when
you look on Jesus and you believe in him
as the son and trust in him for your
salvation, you're wiped clean. It's like
your sins never existed. It's like your
sins never existed and you're a new
creation in Christ Jesus. That's what he
says. You're born again. Okay? So if
you're facing God today on judgment day,
you're going to go to hell. You'll be
guilty because you you've lied before.
Have you ever stolen anything, even if
it's small? No. Never stolen. Have you
ever looked at a woman with lust?
>> You never looked at a woman and said,
"Hey, you just lied again." Look, you
just lied again, man.
You lied. See, see, when you look at a
woman, there's a difference between
admiring a woman's beauty and then
looking at her with sexual desire. You
get what I'm saying? So, you mean to
tell me that you've never looked at a
woman with sexual desire?
>> You have? Okay. Exactly. So, there that
that there's a difference. You can look
at a woman and admire her beauty. But
then there's a difference between desire
like having that sexual desire, that
sexual urge towards her, that's called
lust of the flesh. Okay? And Jesus says,
even if you look at a woman with lust
like that, we look at her with that
craving sexual desire. You undress her
with your eyes.
>> Then Jesus says, then you've committed
adultery with her in your heart. That's
how deep this stuff is. That's how holy
God is. Is that even in your heart and
your mind, he's he you're guilty before
God. That's that's that's how deep it
is. And so because of that, we need to
be reborn. We need to be made new. We
need to be refreshed. We need to have
the renewing of our mind. And the only
way we can do that is in Christ Jesus.
You understand what I'm saying? So I
want you to think about this seriously,
brother. If you die today, you will be
you'll face God on judgment day. You'll
face him as a liar and you'll face him
as one who committed adultery in your
heart. If you face God on judgment day
and he's holy and perfectly just, would
you be innocent or guilty?
>> So, um, so this say that again.
>> If you face God on judgment day
>> and you face him with the sin of being a
liar in your past,
>> you face him with the sin of lust of the
flesh in the past. If you face God with
these sins, and God is perfectly holy.
We agree?
>> Mhm.
>> God is perfectly just. We agree?
>> Yes.
>> So, he can't just let you go. He can't
just sweep your sin under the rug and
say, "Oh, you're good to go." He's just,
so he has to punish you. So, if God is
holy and just, and you face him with
your sins, would you be innocent before
God or would you be guilty before God?
>> Probably guilty.
>> Probably guilty. Exactly. And so, if
you're guilty before God, like all of
us, you'll go to Would you go to heaven
or would you go to hell if you're
guilty?
>> Hell.
>> Exactly. You'll go to hell. If you died
today, just like every one of us,
everybody here, we would be guilty
before God and deserving of hellfire if
we died with by ourselves.
>> But fortunately,
>> who do we have, y'all?
>> Jesus.
>> Who saved us, y'all?
>> Who took the punishment, ladies and
gentlemen?
>> Jesus.
>> So, in Christ Jesus, we're saved.
Brother,
>> would you like to be saved today? I
mean,
[Applause]
>> so this is what this is, brother.
>> The Bible says this. He says, "If you
confess with your mouth that Jesus is
Lord,
>> and you believe in your heart that he
died for your sins and rose again on the
third day, then you shall be saved. You
will be saved."
>> The Bible says, "For with the mouth, one
confesses and believes." Right? Well,
I'm sorry. With the heart, one believes,
and with the mouth, one confesses to
salvation. And the Bible says that no
one no one who comes to God will he
forsake. If you come to him and you come
to him genuinely, you come to him
honestly, then he says he'll never
forsake you. He'll never turn you away.
So do is it and I'm asking you
genuinely. It's it's up to you, brother.
It's it's in your heart. Do you today
want to turn to God and trust in him for
your salvation? Is that what you want to
do today?
>> Of course.
>> Of course. He said of God, man. Praise
God, man.
>> Praise God.
Man, this man, God is good, brother. He
brought you here for a reason, brother.
So, look, this is what we That's all I
ask you, brother. Do you believe in the
scriptures that we showed you in the
prophecy about Jesus?
>> I believe.
>> You believe? Do you believe that he took
on the punishment that we deserve and
died for our sins, died for your sins?
Do you believe this?
>> Yeah, I believe it.
>> Amen, brother. Do you believe that on
the third day, he rose again in power
and authority? Do you believe this?
>> I believe that.
>> Amen, brother. Hey. So today, brother,
today you are now a new brother. You're
a new creation. You've been saved.
You're a brother in Christ Jesus.
Brother, you left. Amen. Let's praise
God for it, man. Let's praise God for
him. This is amazing, brother. Today,
you walk in newness of life. You're a
new creature. Today, this this today is
the first day of your new life. It's the
first day. So, you walk in newness. So,
now what you what you need to do,
brother, find a church. Okay? Get around
some Christians. Find a church. Hey, uh,
you guys out here in New York?
>> You all in New York? All right. So, hook
up with the brother. We got a new
brother in the faith. All right.
>> All right. So, we Hey, we got we got
family here, man. All right. We're not
going to leave you astray. So, you got
family. You got brothers and sisters.
You guys introduce yourselves, you know,
uh, tell them your names where you guys
go to church and let Hey, we got my
brother Tyler right there, man. He Hey,
he'll talk to you, too. All right. And
so, what we do is, but we we fellowship.
We're a family. All right. The next step
is to get baptized. All right. What a
baptism is this. A baptism is when you
get submerged under the water and you
get brought back back up. I seen that.
>> Yeah. You seen that? Seen
>> before.
>> Yeah. So, what that represents is is
when you go down, that's that represents
you dying to your flesh like how Jesus
died and he was buried. When you're
raised up from the water, that's you
being resurrected to new life just like
Jesus. Okay? So, that's what the baptism
represents. And so, Jesus says, "Go out
and make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit."
So, we're supposed to do this in the
name of God. Okay? So we do this as an
outward declaration of our faith showing
that we've died to oursel and we're
raised to new life in Jesus Christ. All
right my brother. Hey hey hey don't
change your name too. Keep Farooq. So
don't Yeah. Keep that name man. God
bless you man. Yeah let's pray for him.
Yeah let's pray for him. Let's pray for
him. Can I pray for you?
>> All right. For sure. All right. Father
God we thank you for bringing Farooq
with us today.
>> We thank you for opening up his heart.
We believe that it's you who led him
here. Lord God. You planted the seed and
you grew the seed. And because of this,
we now have a new brother in the faith.
We have we now have a new brother under
you, Lord God. You have a new son in
your kingdom, God. And we know the
angels are rejoicing. The angels are
celebrating. And so are the saints. All
the people of God, we worship you, God,
for bringing us our new brother. Lord,
keep him strong. Give him wisdom in how
he walks. Give him understanding in how
he walks. Uh uh equip him, Lord God.
Bring new people in his life and good
people in his life that will help guide
him, Lord God. Lead him by your holy
spirit. Fill him with your holy spirit
so that he is dedicated to you. That he
has a zeal for you. That he has a fire
for you, Lord God. Fill him up with your
spirit, Lord God, of peace, of
understanding, of strength, Lord God,
and not of fear. In the name of Jesus,
we pray. In the name of the father, the
son, and holy spirit. Say amen.
>> Amen. Glory to God. That was nice to
meet you, brother. God bless you, man.
God bless you, brother. Amen. Amen.
Let's give God a hand praise, man.
Let's give God a hand praise. New
brothers. Amen.